chris we're here
and it's a strange time in the sports
world it is and i think that
it's one of those moments
what happened yesterday that shared
collective
loss shock stun grief
i compared it to the passing of a pope
the passing of a president for me and
this is before your time when elvis
presley died sure somebody that everyone
knows knows of has seen grow up right we
became aware of kobe bryant in
yeah when he was 17 years old youngest
player ever done in the nba right he
matured before our eyes highs and lows
ups and downs the life that we all live
right it's not all great all the time
but we saw him come out on the other
side and the thing about kobe bryant who
died yesterday in a tragic helicopter
accident in southern california making
it worse his 13-year-old daughter
seven others were perished in the
accident but there was something about
kobe bryant that has really pulled
everyone together in this morning in
this moment of
of uh reflection and and grief and loss
and it's a shared loss that crosses all
lines of sport crosses beyond sport it's
a shared common american and global
experience it's uh it's a first for me
and i think for really anybody part of
my generation who was maybe born in the
early 80s to have
this type of icon uh in the sports world
just pass away out of nowhere like this
you know really in my lifetime being
born in 1980 uh i mean michael jackson
was a big deal when he passed away a few
years ago things like that but nobody in
the sports world that i think and i
don't know who that would be maybe to
your generation growing up i know like
roberto clemente would he be in that
conversation but yeah yeah
big deal that that uh i was i was six or
seven years old at the time right but
that was one of those where
you know when you're little and you're
like something's wrong with the
grown-ups yeah you don't quite
understand what right but yeah you know
and that was he was on a mission to uh
engage in earthquake relief and the
plane went down and and yeah that was
that probably is the closest thing
my era right yeah right and it's just uh
it's a shame because kobe bryant i know
i grew up watching him i mean like you
said you know i was an impressionable
high schooler when he was coming in the
nba just going oh my gosh this guy this
is unreal and he's really not only what
how great he was he was kind of the you
know next guy after michael jordan which
was huge to my generation as well i mean
he chewed gum like him he acted like um
he had that killer instinct like a
michael jordan did at the end of a
basketball game and really just from
that aspect alone created a culture uh
around himself for being famous for that
for being like you know
oh the game's on the line no big deal
i'm kobe bryant i got ice in my veins
give me the ball and that's the thing
that i will always remember about kobe
bryant just doing whatever it took to
win a game practice whatever it may be
the sacrifice from a talented guy to
work as hard as he did i think was
really rare and i think that's key
there's a lot of guys who don't have the
talent who put in the work to maximize
it he's one of the few that has the
incredible high level guardian ability
and
did everything he could to get the most
out of it to the point where
it inspired athletes
in every sport it inspired basketball
players baseball players football
everything everything it crossed all
boundaries and he was an example a
universal example to athletes and really
to anybody who's paying attention yeah
you know we all if we want to have any
degree of success in our lives we have
to have a work ethic to get the most out
of the talents we're given i mean that's
that's the parable of the talents you
get the most out of what god gives you
that's your obligation and just because
you've gotten a lot and it's easy
doesn't mean you just coast yeah you put
the pedal to the metal even harder and i
know you've spoken to guys like aaron
rodgers about how right
that inspired him seeing the example
that kobe bryant well to everything you
just said i think you know michael
jordan was that guy right who had
incredible talent and worked hard and
then kobe bryant kind of took it over
and taught the next generation of
athletes how to be like that and yeah i
mean i was with aaron rodgers this year
at lake tahoe you know walking two holes
with them and kind of just talked about
you know what what gets you up in the
morning what drives you
and he told us a little story about him
reading about kobe bryant getting up at
3 30 4 in the morning and he thought wow
well if kobe's waking up that early i
got to start getting up that early too
and it changed the way he started to
train and approach his professional
lifestyle from kobe bryant let alone all
the people he is affected in the nba i
mean i'm just you know i can still
remember the olympics back in i want to
say it was 2008 with lebron and
everybody like that where he was waking
up early before practice doing these
workouts by the second week
the whole team was doing it with them
and i think that just tells you the
sacrifice and the talent that the guy
had people saw it they gravitated
towards it and yesterday hurt it really
did it was it hurt i don't know what
else to say maybe more because i'm a
father and he had a 13 year old i've got
a 13 year old daughter
where i just could not
i can't i can't uh put myself in their
family shoes right now it's
devastating it's a legend and uh so
sorry to see it happen in all nine past
in that helicopter crash in southern
california kobe who was 41 his
13-year-old daughter gianna he survived
by his wife vanessa and three other
daughters natalia bianca and capri again
seven others on that helicopter
including orange coast college
basketball coaching legend john alto
belly and his wife carrie and their
daughter alyssa on their way to a
basketball game yeah kobe was very
involved in his daughter's basketball
career right uh promise at 13.
significant promise and uh just the the
thing about kobe bryant
that and and i don't follow basketball
like i used to yeah i got to go all in
on football to stay up to speed on
everything that's happening and that but
but i've picked up
a sense just this vague sense that for
him the ending of his playing career was
just the beginning of something else
that was bigger that was vague that was
to be determined and seemed unlikely in
that way right right right with other
athletes it's like okay they're done
playing what are they going to do now
right for the next 40 or 50 years but
with kobe it just felt like there was
something
it was a bigger play yes that was yet to
be unveiled is that i i i think it's i
think it is i think he made a really a
drastic jump from being this guy who was
like so focused ultra
i'm going to be the greatest basketball
player ever all those type of things to
where yeah he looks like he had
refocused it and won an oscar what was
that two years ago when he won the oscar
uh so i i do think between that and
where he was going for the basketball
yesterday was what the the mambo
mentality right that's where they were
going where they had these games for
youth and everything like that he was
really making a mark uh in the community
throughout the la area and it's uh yeah
it's a shame to see him go because he
was kind of becoming a special what what
do you say philanthropist there that way
won the academy award two years ago for
best animated short film for the film
dear basketball will be enshrined in the
hall of fame
uh in september and one thing i noticed
yesterday
and and you know the the other angle to
this
to have this play out in the age of
social media to the point where it now
is you scroll through twitter and you
see how
how heavily it affected so many
different people yeah everybody you know
and people were numb dumbfounded and you
could just see and you could sense from
football players from anyone the the
loss that they felt and this is one of
those moments where it pulls everyone
together and it causes a lot of
reflection and uh
and it causes a lot of grief and and
it's just something that it just it it's
it's there and you know we're here to
provide alicia keys she brought him up
at the grammys i mean that just i think
speaks to what you're saying the
crossover of like the personality the
person the icon he was in the sports
world you know like him or not right uh
you you had to respect him that's the
one thing i think you have to say about
kobe bryant his respect for his love his
work ethic his true like fire i mean you
know he got that that mystique the mamba
because he was a killer on the
basketball court you know for for lack
of a better phrase there i mean you just
knew oh he's got the ball in his hand at
the end of the game it was just like
michael jordan you were just like he's
going to come through he's going to hit
a fade away j in your face and then pump
his fist as he walks down the floor i
mean he had that type of way about him
to where i think any athlete playing or
any entertainer could really respect
that aspect of them